what's up believe nation today we're
going to talk about seven new ways to
make money on the side so I can ask this
question a lot how do I make money on
the side how do I turn you know my job
into a business then I can get my side
hustle up first and then create a
full-time income off of that or how do I
take my business and add something a
little bit on the side that helped me
grow so today I'm going to give you my
seven ways from making money on the side
[Music]
we number one is to volunteer wait what
I thought you said I'm making money on
the side not only the volunteer
volunteering and creating spec work is
one of the greatest ways that get
opportunities to help you develop a
relationship there was an example I look
at videos you guys like my videos you're
watching this video now one of the guys
that is some video work his name was
rich and he started off by making a
belief ba you got a love on the channel
and he volunteered and created that
video for me since then he's come in and
done some some videos on spec where he
was on camera and he was also behind the
camera filming I've done some video for
his channel and we expanded that to him
getting paid to create some videos for
the channel he was into a certain kind
of video some motivational videos and he
had an idea to match that with something
I wanted to create and then I hired him
to make some videos for the channel
and so that fact worked that volunteer
work led to a relationship which led to
me hiring him sticking with the video
world I think about Gary Vaynerchuk and
how his videographer is guy named D Rock
pitched him on doing a video series
saying hey I think you should be filming
your content I think you got to be out
there you're a thought leader I want to
help I'm a videographer he did one
project he did one video I think it was
the clouds and dirt video on Gary's
channel and it took off and it did well
and Gary loved it and said you know what
I like this I'm going to hire you to
come on and be it ended up being a
full-time job full-time career for him
and it worked and so a lot of times to
get in the door you got to prove
yourself and a great way to be able to
do it is to volunteer or do some spec
work to show that listen I got talent I
got skills it helps your portfolio but
ideally you're working with companies
and with people
who can turn into paying clients at the
initial project design number two is to
be a connector I'd be looking at what
are some opportunities that are out
there where I could be a salesperson for
with businesses or individuals that I
know have a need so as an example I look
at here trying to dance salsa one of my
assistants at the school her name is
Claudia she has a business where she is
reselling Internet services and so she's
talking to the companies that she's
connected with and I want to help her
out I'm actually paying more to work
with Claudia than I would for my normal
intimate provider because I want to
support her I want to support her
business her mission what she's on and
she has a full-time job and this may
become something that becomes a bigger
part of your career path and maybe it
doesn't but I'm doing it because I want
to support her and all she is doing is
being a connector right she introduced
me to the service provider and she gets
a monthly commission for every time I
spend money you know paying my you
monthly internet bill and so you can do
that you can look at who is already
hearing that where Kirino has a need go
help them solve that problem and take a
commission off of every sale that's made
if you really love doing that and you go
all-in on it that can be your start just
start selling other services taking
commission at the start but the more you
get to know these businesses the more
you care about helping them the more you
really understand their problems the
more pain that you see there the more of
an opportunity creates for you to find
other services to help them you don't
have the created income scratch at the
start you're just being a connector
bringing two parties together who could
use each other number three is extend
somebody else is offering so whatever
product or service that you can
potentially bring to a company I've been
looking at how can I extend somebody's
existing offering so can you build an
app for somebody who you know as a
thought leader I want to get into
potentially a business you know if you
sell t-shirts can you be the t-shirt
provider for this person's now can
potentially expand a business right like
a TDS we're looking at bringing in
t-shirts for the students and for the
instructions for the helpers I'm
actually struggling to find a local
company that doesn't suck with their
service to give money to to help me
t-shirts right so can you look at how
can you extend somebody's current
business help them make more money help
them grow into a new market by working
with you on a new potential project if
it's too far outside their realm then
maybe it's not a fit but if there's a
natural logical extension of their
business then it's worth reaching out
and showing what you can do
[Music]
number four sell your sada
I've been looking at one of the things
that you are doing in your day to day
activities things that you throw away
that you may be able to sell so as an
example look at my high school cafeteria
and one of the things that we would do
back in high school back in the day is
any extra food we had we would throw
into a special garbage Prince we'd have
a garbage bin for the garbage and a
garbage bin for the food and then the
school sold that excess food to farms
where they would feed at the pigs and
other animals and so selling your
sawdust is an analogy for selling your
garbage selling your waste products
sawdust was considered a waste product
right you're cutting wood there's
sawdust on the floor that's garbage you
throw it away you really take like I
could actually sell that and make some
money off of it so look at your current
process look at what you're currently
making in the in your business as a
product or service I look at the things
that you just take for granted things
that you just throw away think that it's
just considered a waste product and see
how can i potentially sell that to other
people so another example is people who
are selling ebooks based off their
knowledge so people who have built up
the business they've created successful
YouTube channel and the product is the
YouTube videos
alright the product is the things that
you can see when a daily day basis on
YouTube the sawdust would be the entire
process of picking the right camera and
getting better on camera themselves and
the gear and the strategy and the SEO
and all that stuff that can be turned
into an e-book can we turn into a
mastermind session it can be finding the
coaching you can returning to a physical
book right it's the byproduct of your
actual product or service so the stuff
that you know the stuff that you maybe
take for granted the stuff that you're
just throwing away or saying like I know
that already can be turned into a prior
to service and you could sell the other
[Music]
number five is solve a problem and at
the end of the day business is about
solving problems if somebody has a
problem and you can find a solution for
them then you're in business and it may
not be a massive business at the start
but if you're looking at your friends
you're looking at your family you're
looking in communities that people who
are already around you when they're
complaining about something when they're
frustrated about something which is how
many conversations have you had with
people where they're complaining right
lots every time you hear somebody
complaining look for an opportunity like
here's a friend of mine who is in pain
who has a need huh can I help them solve
that is there an opportunity here does
it line up with something that I'm
excited about that I might be able to
guide them through if you can solve a
problem for a friend if you tell a
problem for yourself that someone is
willing to pay for one person is willing
to pay for you know a thousand people
willing to pay for they can do start of
a new business number six is get a
part-time job and again you may be
thinking what I thought this about how
to make money on the side as an
entrepreneur listen one of the best
things that you can do to get an
education as an entrepreneur is to go
work for somebody who's done what you
want to do yes there is definitely value
and you being out and you hustle you
trying to learn everything yourself and
being in the business there's also a ton
you can learn from somebody who's
already done and so if I had a business
and I wasn't making the money that I
wanted to wasn't having an impact that I
wanted to felt like I should be growing
a lot faster than I currently was I
would go try to find somebody who was in
that business who has ten employees or
less who's a company that I look up to
that I would want to be in a couple
years and find a way to work with them
find even some part-time saying to work
for them freelance outsource my services
to them to be a part of their ecosystem
to get as close to the founder as
possible because the point of getting
the job is not just the money to learn
let's understand how that industry works
how they get business how they get
customers how they've grown and take
that back to make your business stronger
and so getting a part-time job can be a
great way to invest in yourself not just
to make a paycheck but to get the
education while getting paid normally
you pay for education here you are
getting paid to learn
and make yourself better as an
entrepreneur and number seven is build a
foundation I think to many people when
you're looking at making money on the
side are just looking for some quick
cash something that's totally unrelated
hoping they don't really care about have
a passion about and if that's your
mindset and you're always going to be
stuck there you're always going to be in
like the next quick deal the next quick
cash your next small thing and you're
always doing small deal too small deal
too small deal well if you want to have
ultimate success it's going to come from
building something bigger and it starts
with having a foundation so a YouTube
channel is an example right you may
start it off and at the beginning you're
not getting a ton of return right you're
not making a lot of money off
advertising you're not getting a lot of
traction partly because we're still
working on your own skills because
you're not great at being a youtuber yet
it's okay it's a start expect to suck at
the start that's what happens but you're
building a foundation if you keep
working at it keeps getting better you
keep improving you keep grinding you
keep hustling it builds and the builds
and it builds and it builds and you
start making more money and you start
making more collaborations or you start
getting more brand yields when you start
gaining more opportunities because every
day you taking a step forward
that you can turn this side thing at the
start which unrespected YouTube channel
on the side which was for me my youtube
channel was a side hustle I had my
business and YouTube was something that
I wanted to experiment with and try and
I tried it and I've improved improved
improved and proof I took a break for a
while I came back to it improved
improved improved improved and now it's
a significant chunk of what I do or
where I spend my time and so I always
have an eye towards if I'm picking
something that I want to do on the side
its leading towards something bigger
because if it's not leading towards
something bigger and I'm always going to
suck playing the small game I'm always
going to be stuck doing the small deals
I'm never going to reach anything Matt
those are my thoughts my seven ways to
make money on the side some new ideas
for you hopefully you enjoyed them I'd
love to know what did you think what was
your favorite rule what are you going to
try to implement in your business your
life also did I miss an 8 9 10 and
something you want to add to the list
that you has helped you that you want to
bring value to believe nation I really
appreciate it leave it down the comments
below and we're joined in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
t-to believe in yourself and whatever
your one where it is let's love